great cold open but is there really room
for both of them in this pool sure it
might be deeper in the middle but it was
also perfectly still what were they
doing in there spooning part of me
really wants to love this witcher look
but there's something unnerving about it
that i just can't put my finger on wait
el news is new guest today isn't your
day is it geralt of rivia is a dick to
bambi we don't want your kind here
witcher that's witcherist want some
breakfast i'm full
venison filling in conversation with
more specifics than are asked for
drinking beer with breakfast it's hard
to make a living on main roads and you
desperately need money for new clothes
care more and shaming how much coin feel
kiki more than call me old-fashioned but
i was always taught to at least say
hello before attempting to purchase
someone's kakamora i killed a wrap this
morning with my breakfast fork kids i
can also tell you
that my father will have no use for this
beast kiki more is if she knew that
kikimoras are worthless then why did she
open by asking how much he wanted for it
what was the point of this visual
inspection if she already knew what it
was and in turn knew it was worthless
yes yes this ends up being a ruse but
why not skip this bs and simply tell him
that he'll get a better price from the
creepy sorcerer of creepiness i got 15
crowns for the yappy month that's enough
to buy some new clothes
just saying that's the second person in
this episode to mention geralt needing
new clothes wow i've been sitting here
wondering how cool i would look in that
getup so i'm not sure if this is a sin
for the other characters in this episode
or for my personal taste but i'll just
throw in two for good measure wow
that's my thing
shakira deniers my mother says you're
the offspring of foul sorcery a diabolic
creation filthy degenerate born of hell
the youtube comment section whenever we
send literally any anime that's my name
like milk how the [ __ ] are you spelling
milk what's your name
girls
like garrett no like [ __ ] girl what
is her problem because i'm a girl and
girls can't be witches
which i think is probably the cheapest
thing i've ever heard morilka would be
the siri at tv since am i missing
something here is this the most
pointless use of illusionary magic ever
put to film aren't doors usually created
to keep people out why bother creating
the illusion of a door if it reveals
itself as an illusion as soon as someone
interacts with it as one does with a
door what's to stop any tom dick or
henry from just walking in and if you
don't care why bother with a [ __ ]
door at all what we've done here is
create an illusion of an object that
strips it of its most basic function
why
this scene reminds me of star trek the
next generation's justice in star trek
deep space nines let he who is without
sin and reminding me of either of those
terrible episodes gets you ten cents
each so in order to honor him i've taken
his name as my
personal
super k
if you played a drinking game that
involved taking a drink every time
geralt let out a
or similar grunt you'd have alcohol
poisoning by the 10 minute mark
my own creation imagine being so much of
an [ __ ] that your supply of apples
runs out at such a rate that your only
option is to conjure a garden of naked
women tasked with picking as many apples
of assholery as possible there's no way
you can get five you're not taking a
bite of that bread before i try
considering we find out shortly siri is
not a mere peasant and is in fact
royalty her trying to take bread from
these kids mouse makes her someone very
hard to root for right out of the gate i
did steal the bread coriander
is it too much to ask that you exercise
a modicum of respect discount lannisters
north has been at war since nilfgaard
took ebbing the north guardian force
crossed the arnold pass headed to sodom
if they're smart yay
i think
maybe i mean i'm certain there's a
portion of the audience that reads the
books and played the games and knows
exactly what all this means and are
losing their collective but i haven't
got a damn clue what any of these names
mean or why it's important and i simply
don't have the time or inclination to do
the required reading i'm far too busy
watching shows i don't understand and
nitpicking them for the internet it's a
catchy song three thousand of my men
died three thousand of my men died feels
like more of an emo number my chemical
romance would tackle but it could still
have some catch to it this juxtaposes on
for all the some time why not
kill them because then
i am what they say i am
nope superman the white here is trying
to convince us that killing men in
self-defense would make him a monster
which is just not the case now when
those same men are killed as a result of
some overflowing collateral damage in a
heavily populated area during a battle
with a similarly superpowered being then
we can revisit the who's a monster topic
reading will my grandmother be all right
you will be all right princess yeah well
that's not what she asked is it this
non-sequitur isn't fooling anybody so we
may as well be honest and tell her
straight that there's a good chance her
grandmother will be returning home with
significantly less blood and
considerably more pillagy house
and you're only telling her this now how
long have you been holding on to that
crucial piece of information sir this
isn't a family friend dropping out at
the last second it's an entire [ __ ]
army not showing up is this not the sort
of thing you share the instant you find
it out you know just in case that
changes the
plan of attack i know it's important to
know who's who but in reality why would
you start a battle with a helmet to only
remove the damn thing part way through i
don't care how confident you are in your
abilities this is absolutely asking for
well that
iced not iced wait who's iced again
no the cliche gods have kindly provided
some ominous clouds of smoke to
accompany this siege but have rather
neglectfully omitted the fires that
should be causing them i want to hear
about my first monster 150 miles outside
of cam warren boring your steed with
screens of deeds before they've agreed
to heed she took one look at me
screamed
vomited
and passed out title of my sex tape i
don't pick science
and just kill monsters but that would be
choosing a side right it's an
anti-monster side if nothing else
when i was a girl
my mother used to skip we must go your
height
wow did you see that
those glasses they moved slightly
that's it find geralt the fate of the
world apparently rests in the hands of
princess siri and queen kalanthi here
chooses to spend their last precious
minutes together reciting a chapter of
the idiot's guide to being a monarch
instead of giving her some much-needed
context about whoever the [ __ ] a rolt is
and why he's so important to her future
horses convenient getaway horses of
convenience are very [ __ ] convenient
princess
i gave your grandmother my word
allow me to keep it guardian wizard
figure sacrifices themselves so the
hobbits i mean harry i mean the princess
can escape cliche it seems renfree ran
away in the night but did she take his
armor as well why else would geralt not
wear it into battle it's taking a while
to get here but this fight scene is
totally badass but you leave me no
choice to slap us in straight back
across those perfectly polished pecs for
expecting me to believe that these six
men who know they're fighting a [ __ ]
mutant that hunts monsters for a living
think the best plan of attack was to run
in one at a time like the obedient
murder boner fodder they are magic
doesn't work on me
silver does that but if someone could
use magic to conjure up some silver then
renfree would be dead which she deserves
to be because she gives up the goods on
her weaknesses too easily and she's a
liar
isn't that what you two did last night
wait damn it fine take the sin back
again for this epic sword fighting
choreography but i'm holding this show
personally responsible for poor cindy's
nausea inducing headache standing still
while the ground beneath you is slowly
disappearing
[Applause]
[Music]
bringing stones to a sword fight
[Music]
huh
i'm hexed
by extra mean bat crazy then yeah yeah
today isn't your day is it i've heard
worse you're not a man
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
[Music]
you
shall not
stick them in a stew
i'm going to make them suffer cow
these humans you've adopted i will take
them all from you one by one you're a
monster zod
and i'm gonna stop you
i was traveling by the swamp go
stay on the road
keep clear to the moors